[Musique]
depuis son premier vol
il y a déjà une cinquantaine d'années de
cela le lockheed c 130 hercules s'est
révélé être un des avions les plus
efficaces de tous les temps conçu pour
remplir un nombre important de fonction
il est à l'aise aussi bien dans un
contexte militaire que commercial avec
sa grande capacité d'emport ainsi qu'une
réputation d'appareils économique fiable
et solide
le c 130 est devenu de l'avion de
transport standards par rapport auquel
sont jugés tous les autres avions de
transport
après des décennies d'opérations un peu
partout sur la planète
il s'est affirmé comme le transporteur
numéro 1 faisant preuve d'une
exceptionnelle longévité
on lui a confié toutes les missions
possibles de l' attaque au sol à la
récupération des capsules spatiales
depuis 1954 il a servi avec les forces
armées de plus de 60 pays différents
[Musique]
extrêmement populaire auprès de tous ses
utilisateurs
sa puissance et sa polyvalence on en
fait une véritable légende
[Musique]
le lockheed c 130 hercules le plus
polyvalent des gros transporteurs
[Musique]
en 1951 elle us air force décidé de
remplacer tous ses avions de transport
alors équipés de moteurs à pistons par
une nouvelle famille d'avions équipés
cette fois deux turbopropulseurs
les machines existantes comme le curtis
ses 46 et le c 119 livebox cas avec une
charge utile limitée et nécessitait des
pistes très longue pour pouvoir opérer
avec efficacité la fiche programme
publié en février 1951 exigeait un avion
quadrimoteur capable de mener à bien des
missions diverses en tant que
transporteur de troupes
son rayon d'action opérationnel était
fixée à 2000 km et son volume devrait
être assez grand pour emmener 92 soldats
ou bien soixante quatre parachutistes
équipe est dans son rôle logistique il
devait transporter aux alentours de 16
tonnes de fret sur 1800 km et être
capable de revenir à sa base sans avoir
à ravitailler pour les parachutages
il disposerait d'une rampe de chargement
de bonne taille et serez capable de
voler à des vitesses assez faible
finalement afin qu'ils soient efficaces
sur n'importe quel théâtre d'opérations
il devrait pouvoir se suffire de pistes
courtes et parfois sommaires plusieurs
constructeurs américains furent invités
à soumettre leurs propositions
parmi eux boeing feirstein douglas et
lockheed
bien que les trois autres compagnies et
plus d'expérience dans la construction
d'avions de transport lockheed fit le
pari de concevoir un appareil qui allait
au-delà des exigences basée à burbank en
californie
l'équipe de conception conduite par
willis hawkins opta pour un appareil à l
hôte et fuselage large
disposant d'une énorme rampe de
chargement à l'arrière
la soude principal mesurait trois mètres
de large 2 mètre 75 de haut et un peu
plus de 12 mètres de long ce qui
permettait de charger facilement du fret
encombrants la puissance devaient être
fournis par quatre turbopropulseurs
allison t56 chacun développant 3700
chevaux
disposant des lices tripale pas variable
ces moteurs pourrait donner à l'appareil
un excellent taux de montée et une
vitesse de croisière de 575 km la
proposition de lockheed qui avait reçu
le nom de ses 130 fut soumise à l'air
force en avril 1951
moins de deux mois plus tard il sortit
vainqueur de la compétition
peu de temps après la compagnie reçu le
contrat de construction de deux
prototypes y ces centres 1
le travail débute à l usine de burbank
et en septembre 1952 une commande su
passer pour une première série de 20 c
les prototypes étaient à peine achevée
que lockheed organisait déjà une
production massive à l'usiné de marietta
en géorgie
le premier prototype fils on roll out
durant l'été 1954 et le 23 août
il fit son vol inaugural depuis leurs
bancs aux mains de stanley belt
il dépassait les exigences du programme
par bien des aspects sa vitesse de
croisière était plus élevé et sont tous
deux montés plus rapide que les
spécifications demandées par l' us air
force
en dépit de sa charge utile de plus de
17 tonnes
l'avion était moins lourd que demander
pouvait décoller et atterrir sur des
distances inférieures à celles des
spécifications
l'envergure était de 40 mètres quarante
est la longueur hors tout de 29 m 80
le train d'atterrissage principal était
constitué de deux paires de largeur ou
en tandem pour réduire les risques
d'effondrement lors des opérations sur
terrain mou et sur surface instable en
faisant pivoter le train avant le pilote
pouvait faire faire demi-tour à son
avion en moins de 50 mètres les reverse
des hélices lui donnait la capacité au
sol de reculer et dans les zones
encombrées de faire des virages très
court le c-130 du point de vue du pilote
est facile à prendre en main son cockpit
dispose de la place nécessaire pour
accueillir un équipage de cinq hommes
ce cockpit largement vitrées offrent une
visibilité la plus large possible ce qui
peut s'avérer vitale pour les missions
d'assaut ou de ravitaillement sur
terrain difficile afin de faciliter le
chargement la rampe arrière peut être
ouverte à la même hauteur que les
remorques des camions américains
standard avec la rampe levé et les
portes fermées le fuselage peut être
totalement pressurisé ce qui permet à
l'appareil de voler à n'importe quelle
altitude jusqu'à son plafond
opérationnelle même avec des soldats
dans la soute
les sièges de la soute peuvent être
facilement agencé pour s'adapter au
nombre d'hommes à transporter
et dans le cas de mission d'évacuation
il y assez de place pour 70 brancards
les deux prototypes furent rapidement
suivi par six avions de développement
tous construits dans l'immense usine de
marietta
[Musique]
le premier d'entre eux fit son vol
inaugural en avril 1955 et créer
immédiatement la sensation les
observateurs sur étonné de voir un
appareil si imposant décoller en
seulement 3 100 mètres est monté si
rapidement qu'il avait atteint les deux
mille pieds avant d'être au dessus du
bout de la piste
[Musique]
à la fin de l'année suivante les cinq
machines de production avait été
complétée désigné j c 130 ha
ils formèrent l'ossature du programme
d'essai du c 130
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le seul problème majeur rencontré avec
cet avion fut une instabilité dans le
fonctionnement du contrôle électrique
des hélices la situation fut
temporairement résolu en 1955 lorsque
les hélices tripale curtis furent
remplacées par des hélices contrôler
hydrauliquement construite par la
compagnie aéropro deuit plus tard toutes
les variantes du hercules à partir du
modèle b reçurent des hélices hamilton
standard quadri pâle en 1956 des
commandes supplémentaires se sont
ajoutés à la commande initiale de 20
exemplaires et au début du mois de
décembre
le c 130 hercules commence à entrer en
service au sein du tactique envers
commandes de l'us air force
les 40 premiers avions furent affectés
aux 463e troupe carrière wing basée à
armor dans l'oklahoma
quelques mois plus tard 50 nouveaux
appareils furent livrés aux 314e troupes
car irwing de la base aérienne de
stewart dans le tennessee
en 1958 le tactical air command
disposait d'un peu plus de 150 c 130 à
opérationnel en plus des unités basées
aux usa certains squadron furent basés
au japon noyé en france
lockheed avait d'ores et déjà annoncé
son intention de développer et produire
de nouvelles versions le c-130 b fit son
premier vol en novembre
équipé de nouvelles turbines allison de
4050 chevaux et disposant des lices
hamilton quadri pâle
avec une puissance accrue et une
capacité en carburant de 30 mille litres
le nouveau modèle avec une autonomie et
une masse maximale au décollage
supérieur au c 130 ha
123 appareils furent produits pour le
tactical air command et 40 autres furent
destiné aux clients à l'export de
lockheed
les versions qu'à ses 130 b de
ravitaillement en vol et l c-130 b de
transport furent livrés aux us marines
et à l'us navy et les coast guard se vit
attribuer la version de sauvetage hc 130
b
une autre série de ses 130 b fut
converti à la récupération des capsules
spatiales
il était équipé d'un trapèze rétractable
destiné à attraper les parachutes du
satellite en plein ciel ils furent
utilisés dans le pacifique pendant le
programme discovery
[Musique]
pendant ce temps pour les opérations
dans les conditions extrêmes de
l'arctique et de l'antarctique
quelques modèles à fürth équipé de skis
cette variante qui est devenu le c 130
des disposait de ski de 7 mètres de long
sur deux de large
c'est le plus gros avion jamais équipé
d'un tel système
[Applaudissements]
ces avions furent utilisés pour
transporter les énormes quantités de
matériel indispensable pour la
construction de la ligne de radars d'
alerte dans l'arctique et au groenland
en 1961 la troisième variante commence à
être produite en quantité
il s'agit du c 130 heures
adoptée par l'ua sert force aussi bien
pour les missions tactiques que
stratégique
il devint une des versions les plus
réussis et largement utilisé de toute
l'histoire du hercules une fois de plus
la capacité en carburant fut augmentée
l'ajout de réservoir pendulaires
permanents sous les ailes et de nouveaux
espaces de stockage interne augmentèrent
cette capacité de 19000 à 26 mille
litres de carburant
deux fois plus de ces 139 furent
construits que le total des versions
précédentes
de ces presque cinq cents avions
construit par lockheed les 4/5 furent
livrés aux forces armées américaines le
restant étant exporté vers un certain
nombre d'autres pays comme l'australie
le canada l'arabie saoudite et la suède
un grand nombre de conversions et
dessous version furent tissu du c 130
points de base
la nasa utilisa le c 130 pour les essais
de la capsule mercury qui en a le
premier vol humain us dans l'espace
la capsule fut embarqué est largué un
grand nombre de fois à bord d'un c-130
porte arrière ouverte
la capsule bly sur une plateforme
[Musique]
une fois la plateforme largué une petite
charge explosive éjecte un parachute
frein
[Musique]
ces essais avaient pour but de tester
les parachutes de haute altitude et
d'évaluer le système de recherche et de
récupération une fois la capsule posée
[Musique]
le c-130 plateforme des sciences de la
terre à effectuer des recherches depuis
1969 lorsqu'il fut mise en service par
le centre spatial johnson de la nasa
le centre de recherche m ce rachat la
pareille à la fin 1980 et lui fit subir
d'importantes modifications afin qu'ils
puissent convenir aux projets de
recherche en cours à l'époque ces
recherches couvrait une large gamme
d'études scientifiques dans le domaine
du recueil de données sur les ressources
terrestres l'agriculture la météorologie
la zoologie et la simulation
d'instruments sont des secteurs dans
lequel le c 130 est intervenue la
mission principale du c-130 était de
participer au développement des capteurs
et des techniques de télédétection des
cultures et des ressources non
renouvelables mais aussi à la
cartographie géologique dans ses
missions précédentes le c-130 participa
aux programmes internationaux d'études
de l'océan atlantique et joue un rôle
majeur pendant les cinq années conduire
l expérimentation sur le taux d'humidité
du sol
de plus le système de cartographie
sophistiqué de l'appareil a été utilisé
en vols pour calibrer les satellite
terrestre
ce large éventail de travaux
scientifiques est possible grâce à des
équipements disponibles seulement sur
ses 130 et sur u2 le simulateur de
cartographie ms 001 dispose de huit
chaînes pour couvrir les spectre visible
et infrarouge de caméras vidéo et deux
appareils photo sont installés à bord
comme matériel d'investigation les
appareils photos peuvent utiliser des
pellicules normal ou infrarouge
[Musique]
le c-130 contribue donc activement aux
études scientifiques utile pour le monde
entier
les versions en aval des modèles b et e
furent désignés ces 130 f et c 130j
l'exploit le plus remarquable du
hercules dans la marine fut de se poser
sur un porte-avions
[Applaudissements]
ces essais ont été menés à la suite
d'une demande de la navy à la recherche
d'un remplaçant pour le sait un trader à
l'autonomie et à la charge utile trop
limité l'appareil employé était un casse
et 130 f
les seules modifications apportées à la
viande sur l'installation d'un système
de freinage antidérapage un puits pour
le train d'atterrissage avant réduit et
la suppression des nacelles
d'atterrissement en vol le pilote de ces
essais était le lieutenant james flatte
les trois le copilote le
lieutenant-commandant dubaï ou de buster
wall le technicien de bord yves brennan
et le pilote de sécurité n'était autre
que le pilote d'essais de lockheed tête
limmern junior
[Applaudissements]
les tests ont eu lieu sur le
porte-avions forrestall le 30 octobre
1963 il comprenait des touch and go des
atterrissages complet et des décollages
sans assistance à la catapulte la masse
de l'avion variait de 39 à 45 tonnes
le cas c 130 f fut arrêté en juste 90
mètres est lancé depuis ce même point
aidé par un vent relatif de 40me qui
soufflait sur le pont
la mer ce jour-là a été relativement
fort mais avec des vagues de trois
mètres de haut la dextérité du pilote le
lieutenant flatley lui valut la dsi
la capacité du c 130 a effectué des
missions 6 au 10 avait été démontrée
mais le programme n'allait pas plus loin
la raison officielle en était le
caractère trop risqué une autre raison
valable était que le c130 était bien
trop gros pour être garés dans le hangar
ou sur le pont
deux des versions les plus intéressantes
du hercules sur le ac-130 gunship et le
c-130 de commandement et de contrôle
en réaction à l'escaladé des combats au
vietnam
le premier recule à être convertis en
grain chip fut un c 130 ha qui fut testé
en vol pendant l'été 1967
son armement latéral était constitué de
quatre canons rotatifs m 61 de 20 mm de
deux mini gun de 7,62 ainsi que de deux
canons beaufort de 40 mm le ac 130 ha
pouvait donc attaquer des forces
terrestres avec une puissance de feu
véritablement dévastatrice un puissant
phare de recherche était monté à
l'arrière du fuselage permettant aux
équipages du gunship de mener des
missions de recherche et destruction
même de nuit sur les versions
ultérieures la puissance de feu et les
équipements de détection et le blindage
de protection ont été améliorés et au
vietnam
le hercules gunship s'est avéré être un
véritable atout pour transformer un
avion de transport basique en poste de
commandement et de contrôle du champ de
bataille le c-130 lui a certes force mis
au point un poste de commandement de 10
tonnes équipée de tous les systèmes de
communication indispensable pouvant
accueillir jusqu'à 16 personnes
le poste de commandement us c15 a été
conçu pour être glissé à l'intérieur de
la soute cargo d'un c-130 avec le
minimum de manutention
dans ses missions de transport de fret
lourd le hercules fut équipé du système
led ce système de parachutage à basse
altitude idéal dans les situations où
l'atterrissage n'est pas envisageable
des matériels aussi gros qu'un char
léger peuvent être parachuté lors d'un
passage à basse altitude
le fret est protégé des chocs par une
palette adapté est larguée par un
système de parachute qui s'ouvre dans le
sillage de la part lors des essais
conduits au centre de parachutage en
californie une charge de 23 tonnes fut
larguée en utilisant le système lakes
[Applaudissements]
équipé d'un autre système de largage le
maps plusieurs c-130 fut reconverti en
avions de lutte anti-incendie pour lui s
foresterie service
le maf ce module a fire fighting système
permet de larguer environ 12000 litres
de retardant en moins de 10 secondes
au milieu des années 60 lockheed proposa
le c 130 à la certification comme avion
commercial
la première version civile le health en
fit son premier vol le 20 avril 1964 et
reçu sa certification en février 1965 en
1968 lockheed produisit une version
allongée de l'avion le tir est vain à
partir de 1970 une variante encore plus
longue fut proposé connu en tant que
tirer 30
deux extensions de fuselage augmentait
la longueur totale de 2 mètres 70
en dépit du succès de la version eu de
grandes améliorations en termes de
performances ont vu le jour avec
l'arrivée de la quatrième variante de
transport militaire le c 130h
les moteurs allison de 4500 chevaux
chacun lui offrait une vitesse encore
supérieur et lui permettait de décoller
sur une distance encore plus courte
avec à bord un maximum de carburant et
10 tonnes de fret
son autonomie était augmenté pour
atteindre plus de 9000 km
cette avant dernière version du hercules
le c 130h entra en service pendant les
années 70 c'est demain la plus produite
de toutes les versions de l'avion
une fois de plus il connut un grand
nombre de sous version y compris une
version ambulance et ravitailleurs en
vol
tout comme des versions dédiées aux
communications et à la reconnaissance
météorologiques les versions
d'évacuations sanitaires peuvent
emporter 74 patients et trois
accompagnateurs
[Musique]
une version allongée fut proposé ensuite
le c-130 h 30 avec son fuselage allongé
de 5 mètres portant la longueur totale à
environ 35 m le h30 reçu le surnom de
super hercules
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la plupart des versions du hercules du
hameau h furent utilisées avec succès au
vietnam
[Musique]
grâce à sa capacité à assurer une
multitude de missions le hercules a été
l'un des avions les plus polyvalents
engagés dans cette guerre
[Musique]
on
tout en assurant les transports
réguliers les troupes à longue distance
ils pouvaient parfaitement servir aux
approvisionnements par air sur tous les
types de terrain
[Musique]
alors que le système l'aips a été
utilisé pour des largages à très basse
altitude
le système awad pour le parachutage à
haute vitesse a été employé pour des
largages de précision à des altitudes
supérieures à 10 mis les pieds
[Musique]
une troisième méthode connue en tant que
système d'extraction à proximité du sol
utilisaient des crochets attaché aux
palettes de fret
lorsque le hercules arrivait à basse
altitude sur la zone de largage un câble
d'arrêt et est installée par les soldats
sur lequel les crochets s'engageait et
permettait ainsi d'extraire la charge
hors de la soute de l'avion
[Musique]
et
les versions kc 135 employés pour le
ravitaillement en vol des avions de
l'air force et de la navy ainsi que pour
un nombre de plus en plus important
d'hélicoptères
[Musique]
je
pour les missions de combat les guns
chip des versions à eux et h jouèrent un
rôle majeur dans la lutte antiguérilla
au dessus du sud vietnam
[Musique]
on
un vol à basse altitude par une série de
virages serrés à gauche le guen chine
pouvait maintenir sous son énorme
puissance de feu la zone l'ennemi était
suspecté de se trouver
[Musique]
ils furent également employés pour
bombarder les routes d'approvisionnement
depuis le nord vietnam et furent
responsables de la moitié des pertes
subies par l'ennemi sur la piste hô chi
minh
les mc 130 étaient employées pour
larguer des troupes des forces spéciales
engagé dans des missions d'intrusion
derrière les lignes ennemis équipés du
système de récupération felton ils
furent également utilisé pour infiltrer
du personnel et récupérer des aviateurs
qui avait été abattu en vol le système
felton et est constitué d'un harnais
spécial attaché un ballon d'hélium et
d'un système de récupération y fixer au
nez du hercules
[Musique]
après avoir largué le harnais à l'homme
au sol le hercules effectuer une
deuxième passe juste en dessous de la
hauteur du ballon quand la ligne était
prise dans le système de récupération
l'homme était hissé violemment en plein
ciel puis hisser dans l'avion
c'était un système assez sûre et
efficace
[Musique]
après les forces armées américaines le
deuxième plus important utilisateur du
hercules et la royal air force
66 avions été commandée en 1966 et le
premier d'entre eux est entré en service
opérationnel en août de l'année suivante
à partir du c 130h la version de la rs
reçu un système radio un pilote
automatique et un système de navigation
de construction britannique
il fut baptisé hercules ses marques 1
l'équipage standards de la rff et
constitué d'un pilote d'un copilote d'un
technicien de bord et d'un responsable
du chargement
au début des années 70 cinq des six quoi
drones de hercules britannique était
basé à lille âme dans le wiltshire de
nos jours toute la flotte des c 130 de
la rfi est désormais basé
[Musique]
pas
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pendant leurs dix premières années les
reculs transporter des soldats à malte
au belize et en guyane aux caraïbes
il servir à évacuer des ressortissants
britanniques daden d'inde et du vietnam
et effectué un grand nombre de vols
humanitaires lors de famine et de
catastrophes naturelles au pakistan au
sud-soudan en turquie et au nicaragua
[Musique]
en 1981 l'entreprise d'ingénierie
marshall of cambridge commença à
convertir 30 avions ses marques un aux
nouvelles spécifications ses marques 3
conçue à partir de la version allongée
c-130 h 30
la version c3 fait trois mètres de plus
en longueur que le c1
le volume de la soude cargo est augmenté
de 37% et le c3 peut transporter une
land rover supplémentaires ou bien 26
parachutistes de plus
quand l'argentine envahi les malouines
en 1982 le premier recule at any lille
d'asuncion
en moins de 24 heures
bien d'autres suivirent
pendant les trois premières semaines ils
livrèrent 1500 tonnes de matériel
le 15 avril il fut décidé de convertir
le hercules au ravitaillement en vol
en moins de quinze jours de travail
l'équipement nécessaire avait été
installé et testé en vol
cette capacité de ravitaillement en vol
permis aux hercules c est un des
provisionné la task force en mer
au cours d'une opération de
ravitaillement en vol le 18 juin un
hercule établi un record en restant en
vol 28 heures et trois minutes
quatre autres appareils furent modifiées
en c1 cas de ravitaillement en vol et
après la reprise de sun l'est il va en
soutien des f4 phantom désormais chargé
de la défense aérienne des îles
pendant la guerre du golfe en 1990 et 91
la flotte des hercules de la rfm tectoy
un énorme travail
[Musique]
il transportait 50 mille tonnes de
matériel et à tenir un total de 20
millions de kilomètres parcourus pour
cela il consomme r 110 millions de
litres de carburant
[Musique]
en plus de la mission de transport
d'hommes et d'équipements pour les
escadrons de tornado les c1 et c3 furent
chargés du transport des unités de
soutien des brigades blindées en
préparation de l'offensive terrestre
[Musique]
on
en
[Musique]
depuis la guerre du golfe les avions de
ligne ram ont participé aux missions
humanitaires en ex yougoslavie et au
soutien des avions des nations unies
chargée de faire respecter la no fly
zone dans le sud de l'irak
[Musique]
outre ses activités opérationnelles
le hercules participe régulièrement à
des meetings aériens
[Applaudissements]
capable de larguer jusqu'à 60
parachutistes en configuration standard
il est depuis longtemps le largue up
préféré des équipes de démonstration en
amérique et en grande bretagne
la patrouille de démonstration de l'us
navy les blue angels ont pris livraison
de leur premier recul en 1970 et
l'équipe de démonstration de la rfm
emploie également depuis longtemps cet
avion
ayant de multiples démonstrations à
effectuer chaque année les c130 vol des
milliers d'heures pour ces deux équipes
bien qu'étant en compétition avec le f
et la future large aircraft désormais
connue sous la dénomination a400m
le c 130j a remporté quelques contrats
d'exportation en europe
[Musique]